joining me now John Radcliffe former
Trump Director of National Intelligence
Mr Radcliffe you served as intelligence
Chief while much of the censorship was
happening what does all of this mean to
the larger issue of government
surveillance of Americans and do you buy
the government argument here that they
weren't actually censoring anything they
were just pointing tech companies to
problematic content
well I don't buy that argument because
what we've seen here Raymond is this
wasn't just a victory for for free
speech it was a victory for the truth
because at the end of the day you know
as you talked with your prior guests
about what's going to happen on appeal
here the reason I think this bodes well
for the plaintiffs in this case and
frankly for the judge's opinion is so
much of what you were talked about in
your opening that has been was raised as
the matters at issue here about covid
about covet Origins about the efficacy
of treatments about transmissibility
about election interference and Hunter
Biden's laptop it wasn't just that they
were censoring speech about that they
were censoring the truth about those
issues and you know at the end of the
day I think that's going to have an
important bearing here's here's where I
think the problem is going forward is
because uh you've seen this abuse of
these important intelligence and
surveillance tools
and putting
political objectives in front of
National Security they've jeopardized
those so let me give you an example as
the Director of National Intelligence as
you talked about one of the things that
I did was on a daily basis prepared the
president's Daily Brief that's the
collection and aggregation of our most
sensitive intelligence to brief the
president on National Security concerns
one of the tools that we use there was
section 702 of the foreign intelligence
surveillance also the set that's the
same tool that was abused uh to spy on
the Trump campaign and so now when 702
comes up for renewal at the end of this
year you have Republicans saying we
can't renew that in its current form
because it's been abused for political
reasons and and so the the the abuses
these orwellian or abuses that I think
the Judge correctly characterized have
really placed our national security at
risk by these officials putting
political objectives above America's
national security posture is just
incredibly dangerous yeah but you
believe they really need that
surveillance cape ability but it
shouldn't extend to every American who
has contact with a foreigner junk
these are legitimate National Security
intelligence tools that that when used
properly help us to collect Intelligence
on our adversaries that mean to do us
harm but as we've seen and we've talked
about the problem here is that they have
been abused turned inward on American
citizens to spy on them and to use it
for political gain and control and
censor political speech just shut them
up to shut Americans down that you
disagree with or the administration does
John as I mentioned you were running
nationally intelligence when the hunter
laptop emerged now former Congressman
Denver riggleman who's advising Hunter's
legal team claims quote forensics makes
clear that considerable information
linked to Hunter Biden is questionable
what data is being used a laptop and
data saying it's a laptop are two
different things I'm not even sure what
that means but I think what he's getting
at is data mining he's questioning the
data mining do you buy that argument and
is the laptop material inauthentic
well I don't buy it because I I've
spoken directly to the principles
involved in this look on October 18th of
2020 I came out as the Director of
National Intelligence and publicly
issued a statement saying Hunter Biden's
laptop is not Russian disinformation we
have no intelligence that it is
Raymond that was based on conversations
with attorney general Bill Barr an FBI
director Christopher Ray uh who related
to me that the laptop had been verified
by the FBI and was being used in
connection with a money laundering
investigation that was ongoing so you
know uh the the sad thing is at the very
same time that those representations
were being made to me you had FBI agents
in the field going to Twitter and and
shutting down saying hey this could be
Russian disinformation so you know again
we have this problem of of of political
partisans being embedded within the
Department of Justice and the FBI and
it's why it's a problem that the next
Republican president's going to have to
address yeah the the John we certainly
had misinformation the problem is it's
coming from this Administration thank
you for being here hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else